[Musique]
qu'on se le dise bande des appartements
c'est marrant mais c'est aussi usant
c'est en tout cas ce que semble penser
stéphane plaza qui depuis 2006 sur m6
nous fait visiter maisons appartements
grenier à rénover et autres fonds de
commerce a transformée en loft design
mais les émissions d'immobilier stéphane
semble en avoir plein la double vasque à
la tête de nombreux formats autour de
l'immobilier comme recherche appartement
ou maison chasseur d'appartement que
chez soi
maison à vendre stéphane plaza a besoin
de souffler d'autant qu'en plus de ses
activités de vendeur de parquets
l'animateur est également sur les
planches conjugue son métier d'agent
immobilier dans la vie d'animateur à
l'écran mais aussi de comédiens sur
scène une triple vie qui le conduit
aujourd'hui à vouloir passer la main et
stéphane a déjà sa petite idée en tête
le candidat idéal pour le remplacer à la
tête de l'une ou plusieurs de ces
démissions est une femme
il s'agit de l'agent immobilier sandra
viricel j'ai besoin que prenne une
décision qui me disent oui j'y vais déjà
connu des téléspectateurs de l'a6 ce
changement permettra à l'animateur de
prendre un peu de recul pour lui il
s'agirait d'un changement dans l'air du
temps
et puis une femme qui prends ma place je
trouve ça bien un changement qui ne
devrait cependant pas intervenir tout de
suite
alors stéphane plaza a trouvé son
remplaçant bonsoir bonsoir là je suis
tombé sur le champ il est directement
oui non mais en fait c'est c'est mon
info en fait c'est moi qui la disent oui
je tiens plus
et en fait on discutait parce que là il
fait lire à la 100e qui sera diffusée la
semaine prochaine
on discutait jeudi si jamais un jour tu
dois arrêter de qui est ce que tu
prendrais moi j'étais plus team thibault
chanel qui travaillent avec lui depuis
le premier jour et lui préférait que ce
soit sandra viricel si jamais un jour
ils venaient arrêter ce qu'il faut
savoir qui travaille en plus avec le
gouvernement pour aider à une loi pour
aider
il l'est de la ministre bref donc là
beaucoup de choses et il me dit mais
d'un autre côté c'est pas pour tout de
suite là je m'éclate encore pas mal je
suis plutôt bien payé donc si jamais
quelqu'un de remplacer ce sera sandra
viricel parce que j'aimerais bien que ce
soit une femme qui le fasse à à ma place
donc pour la connaît pour l'instant on a
un nom variés que non d'ailleurs
c'est un compliment en tant qu'élite pas
le terme remplaçant que certaines bonnes
âmes me gêne un peu ce qu'il est comme
on l'a dit en rigolant irremplaçable
dans le sens où c'est un concept à
lui-même c'est une marque donc plutôt
vaut mieux créer peut-être un programme
autour de cette jeune fille avec
d'autres animateurs mais c'est un bazar
restera le mister immobilier de france
est à dire qu elle même pour faire des
affiches partout il ya des agences
immobilières partout là c'est tellement
collé à lui qu'on ne peut pas prendre la
relève
autant on a vu jean pierre pernaut à la
relève peut de fait avec en plus une
famille tant mieux au moins ya pas de
comparaison en plus cela autant tout
repose au tour stéphane plaza c'est une
marque aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'elle
est partie de ses animateurs ont dit pas
on va regarder maison à vendredi on va
regarder plaza art et paiera tous ont
dit jeudi opposé moi c'est toi qu'on va
femmes
je suis toujours à l'antenne que je tout
va bien je crois mon coiffeur
l'albertaine sur l'émission envisagée
très bien mais pas maintenant
[Rires]
les surprises que vous ayez une émission
mazza c'est un de mes animateurs
préférés avec vous s'il devait être
remplacé il a beaucoup de choses et là
il est très malin s'ils disent à emilie
c'est un teasing c'était tente de lancer
un nom pour voir et que ce soit je dis
moi oui parce que si c'est une femme et
si c'était elle elle est super j'en
serais enchanté personne est normal que
je le rate jamais une de ses émissions
le problème c'est qu'il va faire que des
comparaisons avec le habituel la fin
avec lui et stéphane plaza
si c'est pour l'envoyer valdinguer comme
ça pour rien ça ils sont reloués de
faïza alors moi je fais partie de ceux
qui pensent un format fort peu peu peut
survivre seul il a lancé tout en
appliquant quelques années c'est pas
comme s'il a amené quelqu'un de nouveau
elle est là depuis et je croyais à
l'arrivée à la doute troisième catégorie
04 2010